and this time of year they're just heart
it's the harvest they're sprouting up
[Music]
you or her like old prom dress to a ball
that we went to on Saturday I am from
the 70s I'm actually 45 years old yeah
that's up today's very special day today
is the day that Dobie has decided to
come visit us once a year
Adobe Oh baby Oh be shown something goes
this time to upgrade all your software
and we're like what it's like I did it
you're welcome he comes we're like what
Dobie comes up and he flies down to this
little sphere when you're sleeping and
he gets yeah basically I have an entire
Gabe's been an entire day synching audio
for our latest tank shoot and then I
just spent the last the beginning of
today like going through and cleaning up
the rest of the files making sure it's
ready to go so it's ready to head at
night I literally click on a clip to
view it and the whole application
crashes it is like this it's like if
this is Dobie 2018 like literally the
most basic functionality of premiere
which is opening video clips to view
them crashes we generally have a rule of
thumb when the very first Nooyi
iteration of Dobie comes out you don't
do it you hide you hide everyone hides
when Dobie flies past and they're like a
couple bystanders get stabbed and you
wait for a like that does the clear and
then you come out but we're too big and
Dobie saw us no he smelled us it's like
when these computers smell like they
have an update
yeah at night they're just like like
flies past every year and he never snaps
up with a spear it's safe outside nope
there's no pool tables near here there's
no cool tables what an obscure I did
this I'd like Gabe like being a friendly
guy and being friends with Toby in like
jumping to 2018 you know it started with
Carmichael ushering Dobby 2018 and or
this Michael
[Music]
it's like a vampire you got to invite
Dobie into your house yeah you know like
a trickster god of sorts who will help
you but also like we'll take something
from here but instead of like being your
door for a vampire it's a boxer says do
you want to allow system Dobie make
changes to your system as an
administrator I love it bring up the
recovery file all right here so here's
the moment of faith a moment of truth
all right I mean V 2 V 2 a David
whatever I can be you have to print you
have to please Dobie already the first
clip or two might work backward works
you play in that clip works all right
let's fly closer to the Sun Toby's grace
by Toby's grace what a terrible error
it's like man come on premier you got to
get of these two things you gotta have a
time line and you got to just play the
video clip okay so uh well that puts the
whole project about a day and a half
behind yeah
so cuz we haven't gotten anything done
it's all happening here in the middle of
bram week yeah let's Bramley q0 oh boy
hey Jake what's brand week this is a
perfect time to talk about what really
is yeah like this is brand week right
here yeah there you go
so yep so brand week is the time out of
each year when all the companies have
all their marketing budgets and happens
to be about a month and a half before
Christmas
slash right when Black Friday is about
to hit all these budgets hey they don't
know what to do with them they just gets
mad and fast enough they reach out to a
bunch of people like us like everything
else on YouTube let me go hey we would
love to do a brand integration with you
or with you or with you but honestly we
just need to do with everybody right now
because we just gotta make this host
view this money up because it does
sit here forever money goes bad
apparently if you hold on to it guys
don't save it brand week for us is this
one time of year when all these videos
are making our channel we get to
actually get some money behind them
because brands sponsor them it also
happens to be the one time of year when
we have all these like deadlines and
contracts and like we have to give this
video on this date this is the time of
the year when dobby shows up like Santa
Claus at Christmas
Dobby comes by on his Nimbus we just go
around with their little boxes all day
binding Oh found another one a new
sponsorship from recoil and their luck
men took reality guns it's just like we
spend most of the year trying to collect
little sponsorships like this to help on
the studio and this time of year there's
just heart it's the harvest they're
sprouting up another upcoming
sponsorship of the video Oh World of
Tanks no that's like it's like a photo
sir I'm sorry I'm sorry
the brand wait guys but you preserve
those brands because in like three or
four months and it's like being a spring
and all your crops have just about to
grow in the field and ice is just
thawing you need those preserves to last
you Maxie they last you all winter
yeah what's this one Star Wars
Battlefront - ooh well you know it's
it's kind of a delicacy these days
because it's more of an acquired taste
actually you know Star Wars Battlefront
like everyone loves Star Wars but
Battlefront - that's that's for like
only special crowds will over preciate
that well look back in these times when
were there hungry we had a fresh Bram in
like four months and we'll just be
wishing Dobies come on ride
Lenovo's Star Wars lightsaber experience
another augmented reality game Wow
augmented reality games are really hot
they're really popular this fall crazy I
don't know it's just I guess it might
just be the temperature good soil good
soil does that say make my name
that's like running a business yeah that
if you guys are wondering why we're
doing this I'm not like editing right
now
or rather Nick and Carmichael aren't
editing it's because we're having Adobe
issues with the server not that not
these new server we got we had another
little like side servers for the same
Neko channel that uh yeah it's
transferring right now to the VP server
let's go take an hour and a half if it
works Dobby has made sure these guys get
some much-needed on our time in the
middle of the workday there's a hand
signal but the thing is you do it wrong
every time in this place we got to
rethink all the sudden I cuz I spent
today going through all the little in
Batumi there was a couple that were
missed so I had to you know the six
telemarketer today
[Music]